in the same way that the force surrounds
us penetrates us and binds the Galaxy
together the internet is equally full of
Star Wars spoilers right now but I don't
think its success has been a surprise to
anyone according to The Wall Street
Journal Star Wars The Force awakens has
already grows to combine 57 million
overnight just in Canada and the United
States the previous record was held by
harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 2 which hit 40 3.5 million on
opening night the difference here being
that the final harry potter movie opened
on a thursday midnight while star wars
began premiering at seven p.m. on
thursday and if you haven't guessed by
now the film has already broken similar
records in international markets chances
are it won't stop there the force
awakens is expected to break nearly
every box office record including
biggest ever first opening a record
which is also held by the deathly
hallows part 2 it may even set the
record for biggest opening weekend ever
if it can top Jurassic world's whopping
208 million if you're curious whether we
thought Star Wars should be sent back
out on the moisture farms or whether
it's deserving of its own medal ceremony
on Yavin 4 make sure to check out our
spoiler free review of episode 7 i'll
try not to force any more Star Wars
references in here but for more on the
force awakens and Star Wars keep your
tauntaun tied up here at gamespot com
mmm and refrain in the comments were
posting squares you man yes mmm
you